hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna do this
reaction to this
Captain Marvel trailer in just a second
what are you looking at the Marvel amino
app people just wanted to give a quick
shout out to today's video sponsor amino
apps may remember us shouting them out
on a couple of our other previous Marvel
related videos and we're excited to be
working with them again and for those of
you guys who don't know amino is a
massive network of online communities
for both fans and creators of like that
spends pretty much any interest you
could possibly imagine
whether you're a Marvel fan of Harry
Potter fan of supernatural fan if it's
out there chances are there's a
community of passionate people waiting
to welcome you on a me know naturally we
wind up posting a lot about Marvel on
this channel Marvel Feige so for us the
Marvel amino is a great place to share
our videos directly with the Marvel fans
and gather feedback as well as chat
participate in polls share theories
personally John and Joe is checking out
the fan art from people who post there
thank you I do like a good bit of fan
art and speaking of fan art if you're an
imino user or about to become an imino
user send us some fanart of us as your
favorite Marvel hero or villain and we
might just feature the best ones in an
upcoming video share your art with the
world as long as you submit them the
balls in your court people in short guys
with Amino it's easier than ever to keep
up with people all over the world who
share your love and passion for your
favorite fandoms and an end to
contribute to the conversation and you
can download the app free for iOS and
Android using our special link here on
screen or down in the description box or
or or down in the pin comment there's
really no excuse people to not check
this app out and Jon you forgot to
mention don't forget to follow us real
rejects all one word anyway thanks to me
now now on to this video about Captain
Marvel Woman
yeah one trailer
[Music]
captain Marvel's personnel are back
kill it if you have to
what music wow salt and pepper for
watching this again
we already got our tickets tickets I was
I'm so used to the other trailers it's
like so serious and there's no
personality and I don't mean that the
other trailers didn't have personality
I'm just saying they were definitely not
as humorous as this one this one's like
all four personality clarifying a couple
like the Koreans girls here's what you
need to know fine yeah the runge is a
good look for you
those are some cool effects squirrels
shapeshifters clarification yeah why
didn't they give us that see the photos
so what are you
I don't remember I passed learn to
control one for all dude
I'm really digging the music yeah it
reminds me of something and I can't
place it I do love his hair yeah dude he
has to be a bad guy
he has like a gruff sinister quality he
seems like that mentor you trust who
just becomes a bad guy yeah yeah all
right guys now that she has a sense of
humor I'm on board now that she has a
personality I'm all for it guys now that
she smiled yeah yeah that's what I bet
man we have that Marvel fun oh my god
I am so here I cannot wait to go watch
this movie now I've always been looking
forward to this film it's got me more
excited yeah this for some reason the
way this play if this is usual Marvel to
me of how you get your serious trailers
and then you get your fun trailer and
the fun seems very natural sometimes you
get trailers that are like totally
confusing you're like what was one
trailer like this with the other one
really yeah and you're like no it's
Marvel this this is probably a little
more in tune with a lot of the fun vibe
is gonna go I mean freaking the the
scroll sees a woman you know with like a
surfboard yes I'm sure the shapeshifter
the Terminator 3 yeah well this time you
got me looking forward to just seeing
brie Larson and Sam Jackson just kickin
it so fun the Buddy elements like
especially those like cuz I love some of
this as much as we're joking about
personality I really like the pitch that
they brought to this it's like a subtly
joking with each other like subtle
sarcasm I brought that
weirdly when I was watching the trailer
the first time I was a little bit taken
aback by the tone and then when we saw
it again that joke or the photon blaster
I kind of flew over my head yeah the
first time the second time like that's
funny
this looks like a total blast and you
get a lot of other cool images in here
that you get better look at what the
scrolls are you get a better breakdown
Oh like for to make it really clear it
like if you're someone who has to go on
Wikipedia and look up what the scrolls
are idiots
what are you doing watching comic book
movies in 2019 now no one who Scrolls
it's stupid people next you're gonna
tell me you don't know what the Kree are
either yeah I know everything about the
Curia so we can't read you lost totally
a bad day I feel yeah that's like the
only moments he gets to even speak I'm
like you just sound kind of Stern and
gruff and like you're gonna you know
you're one push away from becoming I
forget are we at the point where we
still don't know who Jude laws
specifically playing feel like everyone
sautes marvel but I I think we're at the
points though where Marvel hasn't
confirmed that yet I think unless I
heard we we aren't sure who he's
supposed to be okay I mean you still do
get a lot of the things that you wanted
to talk about how she's a mentee to him
not a Mentos as I first read it oh but
she is fresh though but she is fresh she
is fresh she's a woman
aha the MCU freaking time in the right
guys role this looks like a blast man
I'm really looking forward to this film
and that joke at the end about the whole
shield thing and the music the freakin
music is amazing mm-hmm that was like
awesome music weirdly it kind of
reminded me of a Marvel score mixed with
something by Nine Inch Nails it kind of
reminded me of the song they would use
for 300 or whatever but yeah and to like
I'm saying this sounds like a DC so yeah
I wasn't flashing to DC but then when
you're saying that I was like that's
Sonic Tambor what do you know maybe two
movie studios gonna have great music
that's be on the other there has to be
supremacy alright you know I'm so
confident in our discussion I'm not even
gonna cut it up what
oh my Wow I know run off-road today it's
almost as if I'm going to treat this as
most people click off after the first
action dude so many people are upset
right now but you know what implied it
before that we got it one more thing I
want to give a patron of the day shout
out to a lovely talented beautiful hunk
it dunk a woman
well hunky dunky man I don't know it's
like hunky dory but better better
Adelia chambo Delia Chamberlain my dear
how you doing my beauty queen she was
actually in Colorado while I was in
Colorado and I had no idea we were this
close to actually seeing each other I
know captain Marvel's of film you're
very much looking forward to and you
marvel me you're marvelous you're not
less of the marvel you're marvel more
plus you're a captain captain of
literature captain of fandoms galore yes
and yes yes and you know I'm just trying
to work the title into the show I got it
killing it buddy shouts out to your
little niece that's for girls right yeah
country grace congratulations I love you
my dear anyway guys are you excited for
Captain Marvel I know I am
you guys should subscribe to the reject
nation do that right now please click
that notification bell do that right now
and check us out on patreon sure more
importantly Marvel Amino thank you guys
for sponsoring this video of link in the
description box link in the pin comment
we've worked with these guys plenty of
times our good friends
so please do a solid give them the
follow